just recently on 60 minutes which is a
mainstream media news source you had
someone
who was a navy pilot or a navy sailor
who was admitting that yes he saw ufos
and now the pentagon
the u.s military admits that there are
ufos
they don't know what they are and they
call them unidentified aerial phenomena
uaps right and they're saying okay yeah
we admit that there's something out
there that we don't know what they are
and it has these categories and
characteristics
islam gives the best most comprehensive
explanation of it that makes sense of
everything
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively
more than you're influencing them
positively i think you need new friends
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
welcome back to
the realist podcast we had
two hosts rami is missing but no worries
we got two brothers
brothers how y'all doing today
everyone i'm doing all right
thanks for having me
all right guys so today in this episode
we've got a lot of crazy things that
we're going to get into
especially in sha allah for the next few
episodes to come
and uh i want you give them a little
drip
as so what's to come here
so bro this whole new series this new
chapter that we're starting with the two
brothers here
is going to be mainly revolving around
the concept of
jin in islam which i will let ahmed in a
bit take over and go a little bit more
into
if he will insha allah um we're going to
be talking about various different
concepts relating to jin
a lot of different things that society
deems as you know
supernatural or you know ufos or
extraterrestrial stuff and we're just
going to be bringing back to
an islamic understanding
would you like to introduce or would you
like me to introduce the topic
very briefly i'll very briefly like
start and if i miss anything
we can jump in because i know i will but
very briefly
we'll look at jyn and how that relates
to
psychedelics which is quite an
interesting topic you guys have covered
it on the channel with
brother gabriel as well and that was
really insightful but i think it's a
topic that oftentimes can be quite
interesting and muslims can sometimes
get sucked into it but no one explains
it no one breaks it down so the idea of
this is to really break down the
different concepts
and not just psychedelics but that's
which surrounds it so ufos and
magic and all of these different things
star signs
all of all of it like there's so many
different aspects so in this series
inshallah we want to break it down
make it simple and then relate it back
to islam and explain why
the islamic the islamic way of defining
things and looking at things is the best
and the most simple but also
what it means as a consequence in the
hereafter and so on
[Music]
that's true it's getting more popular
than ever nowadays you have
new age movement you have this new wave
spirituality
you have uh people getting into yoga who
aren't even hindus and then you have
all these different concepts that are
being talked about that are not being
explained
correctly in its historical context it's
being explained in a way that's like a
new fad
or something that's good to do without
realizing the dangers
or the ancient history behind it so some
other things such as
not only psychedelics but astral astral
projection or astral travel
lucid dreaming yoga all of these
trans meditation all of these things
that people are getting into
and you see even even religious people
get into it or
and i'm not just talking about muslims
but christians too can get into this
kind of stuff or
someone will see that okay this is my
religion
but at the same time i'm reading this
book called the secret to help me with
my business
well and all of these things whether
it's drugs or whether it's
this belief in the law of attraction is
all coming from the same tree
and i think for the same if you will
it's not really a tree it's more of a
fungus and i'll explain why
i consider it to be a fungus because
it grows in the dark it's not it's not
something that that gives
you light but people understand it as
something that gives you
um something a blessing or beauty in
your life when in reality it's more
connected with something
more ancient and more dark than that so
with all means if you guys want to
ask a question or if you guys would just
like us to start
uh it's up to you this is your product
even though it's our episode but it's
your podcast
yo i got a quick question for angel
because angela is a new
muslim new reaver so
without going too much into anecdotal
personal evidence
right do you personally have any
relations or experience with knowing
about jin
before islam because i know now you have
a fair bit of understanding compared to
before
oh yeah well i knew about them i just
didn't know they were called jin
okay so what made you know about them i
had
experiences that flag or better words
made me s-h-i-t
we want to say the word for the
algorithm obviously keep it p13
but it uh it definitely scared me
for years and um
when i did research um the names that i
came upon were like
um dark entities and stuff like that
yeah fair enough fair enough yeah
usually
usually they call uh when non-muslims
experience these experiences they call
them entities
and they have their own beliefs around
them but like khalid was saying
in the in the intro islam gives the best
most comprehensive explanation of it
that makes sense of everything
so we made a video we dropped a video on
dmt ufos and um magic
and the link between all of them so the
purpose of that video was to give the
history behind what dmt is
what happens when people smoke it and
the fact that or or
consume it in any way and the fact that
when people do dmt
almost categorically they meet what they
call entities right so they have a name
for it the dmt
entities so after he talks about that
i started talking about ufos and aliens
in the history of that
because again and this is actually a
very interesting time because
just recently on 60 minutes which is a
mainstream media news source you had
someone
uh i think he was a navy pilot or a navy
uh sailor
who was admitting that yes he saw ufos
and now the pentagon the u.s military
admits that there are ufos
they don't know what they are and they
call them unidentified aerial phenomena
uaps so that's the official code for it
in the u.s military
but u.s military is not open about it
right and they're saying okay yeah we
admit that there's something out there
that we don't know what they are and it
has these categories
categories and characteristics right so
i start and
you have different uh space agencies
from other countries
also that research this phenomenon and
look into it and so only recently they
started being more open about
about this with the public saying yes
you know we know that this exists
so ultimately what happened was i in
that video was that i was saying look
people have these entity experiences or
meetings with entities when they're
doing dmt but
we look at alien and ufo uh encounters
or abductions or contact experiences and
i said this
experience is almost exactly the same as
the dmt
experience they're very similar the dmt
entities
and the ufo entities share basically the
exact same characteristics
they give you very similar messages
the people that go through these
experiences
have similar um
symptoms that they experienced and then
when we look back even further in
history right
so people in the past seeing what they
thought were goblins or seeing what they
thought were fairies or elves or so
forth
when you look into the past every
culture had their own point of view on
this whether it was spirits of the dead
or
some type of spirit of nature or
whatever they believed that it was
it shared the same characteristics of
the whole ufo abduction experience and i
went over some books
where researchers talked about that and
these weren't some
mosquito these weren't some
let me close my screen door actually
all right so where was i guys
yes i was talking about how there's a
connection between
all of these different entity encounters
so no matter what
form the entity took whether it was a
ghost or an alien or anything like that
the pattern
of behavior and the pattern behind the
encounter was the same whether it was
drug induced
or whether the person said he actually
saw in his waking
life or whether it was a dream or he
woke up and something was at the foot of
his bed
uh like what he thought was an angel or
a demon or an
alien it was always the same pattern
right
and so we break in in the video in the
course of that video we broke that
pattern down and we said these are
the similar characteristics between all
of these encounters
therefore dmt
entities are the same entities of the
ufo entities
historically speaking shamans did magic
and did certain rituals
or ate certain potions or materials to
make contact with these entities
intentionally
therefore doing dmt is a form or a
branch of magic
and that was the ultimate conclusion and
we were saying to stay away from it
because it's a branch of magic and
there's
a lot of severe consequences that's
going to come from people doing dmt
yeah and that was that's the summary of
our video and if you guys will
yeah there's a question that i have so
there's dnt
that's external but what about the
internal or about the natural
because like um i think it's the pineal
gland does
actually produce a certain amount of dnt
so that's what i found yeah sorry i was
just gonna say that's what i found to be
the most
interesting thing so when i was maybe 9
10 i had a random experience where
i randomly had a lucid dream before that
i had like a couple experiences of sleep
paralysis
and then i had a lucid dream so then i
after that i just went into the spiral
of reading and reading because i was
intrigued and no one had any answers but
being a kid
um you know i as long as i can remember
youtube existed and the internet existed
so
i had almost infinite access of
information at my fingertips
and i just spent time going on on and on
and it was very
like very quickly i learned about what
dmt was and it's produced in the brain
some say it's producing the pineal gland
it has the potential of causing some of
the most powerful experiences you can
have as a human being
so i thought okay that's interesting but
what separates the
experience that or what separates the
dmt that is produced internally
regardless of where it's produced if
it's in the brain and the lungs wherever
we don't actually know for definite
but obviously they're theories but we
don't know if we're definite but what
separates that from
externally is you can't have entity
encounters
on an internal experience so you may
reach a different state of consciousness
or alter state of consciousness which we
can talk about in a dream
which is naturally produced anyway it
doesn't mean it's necessarily a bad
thing because that's something that
is given to you by allah and you just
have it we don't know what the role of
dmt is in the body
um that's a mystery it's one of the
greatest mysteries that
human beings haven't solved i think why
is it there we won't know
um is it linked to the soul maybe maybe
that's what it is
but maybe it's not so it's just right
now we can only speculate and we
probably
won't know for sure ever because we're
never going to really understand what
the soul is
and in one a in the quran in surah islam
talks about the soul and the the jews
will ask him muhammad ali sallam about
say that the soul or knowledge of the
soul is
from the matters of your lord so and we
only have only but a little bit of
knowledge so we don't know much about it
and we never will it's something that
allah knows and he's given us a tiny
amount in the quran
in the hadith literature but yeah
i think it as for what's different is
for me the main thing is the entities
and two the steps that you have to take
to get
to a breakthrough dose whether that be
on dmt or ayahuasca is a lot
and you can't produce that much
naturally so regardless of what the role
of the dmt is in the body
it's not the same as taking that larger
dose externally
to put that into your bloodstream and
then have those experiences which are
very specific
and occur in a very similar headspace
regardless of what culture or
time period you come from
[Music]
so i have a question but i feel like i'm
gonna get ahead
of y'all here because uh me fired and uh
we were talking about this during a call
so i i'll let you speak about it which
is the barriers
like that breakthrough they call it
breakthrough for a reason now that
you know when you think about it in
terms of barriers too
which is very interesting yeah
yeah the barriers that like that
breakthrough experience
yeah so so well you were talking about
the um
uh the barriers in terms of like when
you meditate you are
lowering your barrier um when you do
yoga so
i was saying that again this is all uh
type of speculation we don't really know
how these unseen matters work
but ultimately when someone
starts involving themselves in these
activities
the the jinn so for those viewers that
don't know in islam allah created men
mankind from clay and allah created the
jinn from
a smokeless type of fire so we can't see
them
they're made of what if you if you will
energy based intelligence and allah
created the
angels from light right so the jinn like
human beings there are many different
tribes there are many different types
uh some of them are muslim some of them
are christians some of them are
shayateen or sata or followers of satan
and they fulfill his orders and
try and influence human human beings by
whispering
for them to do certain things and so
forth
so when someone gets involved
in magic practices whether they realize
it or not
it's in a way inviting jinn to come into
their life
and these jinn are not going to be the
good type of gin because they're not
they're not supposed to possess you
right so already if something
is happening and they're trying to
influence your life in that way then
they're they're basically going to be
the ones that are evil
right they're not going to be the gin
that are oh you know because you hear
some people say this oh you know but my
the my uh the gender that i've spoken
with
is a good is a good one first of all
there's no way you can
you can know that because they're from
the uh it's not like a human being where
you can verify the information that
they're saying you can't verify anything
that they're saying
and second of all if they're talking
with you
and they're trying to influence your
life in some way then you already know
that that's that's a serious red flag
and we'll get into why that's a serious
that's a serious problem later but
when someone involves themselves in
these type of things they're basically
inviting the jin into their life so in
some way
the barriers that allah puts that
protects us from this and our prospect
has given us
that we say before we enter the home so
for example say something before we
enter the home
some things that we say before we even
have sex with our wives some things that
we say before we say bismillah
and this prevents the jinn from coming
with you
involving themselves with your food or
eating your food while you're eating it
or even at some point uh joining you in
sexual relations with your wife so
probably
has taught us all of these different
zikr and that we say before we do
anything
that protects us from shape on trying to
influence that matter
right so magic is the opposite of that
it opens it up so that margin can
influence that matter or whatever you're
trying to do
and that comes with serious harms and
serious repercussions so
uh yeah i'll take it back to you uh
brother fenin
yeah i think we'll probably get on to
this either if not
in this episode another in terms of
meditation yoga et cetera
and other states so astral projection
what is lucid dreaming what are all of
these different things because
these are concepts when you learn about
one you're never if you're going to
follow it for a long enough you're
inevitably going to find out about
another
and another so you learn about
meditation and you go into yoga
and you take and it's like a almost like
this this pathway that i think a lot of
people
have followed i myself have um
looked looked into it as well in the
sense that i used to
read a lot about it and it used to
intrigue me what i think is
it's kind of similar like you say like
it breaks down you start breaking down
these barriers so
it's pretty much just echoing what
you've said instead of
um building up these barriers to protect
you from them you're kind of opening
yourself to them you'll see
some benefit and there is some benefit
which is why you'll carry on doing it
you'll see some sort of improvement
mentally physically i don't know uh
depends from person to person and
activity to activity
you will see a benefit uh which is what
is
which is what why there's this almost
hype about it there's this
i guess
the thing is like you take some people
who do
who focus on zen buddhism or qi or if
you look at tibetan buddhists
they have all of these practices um and
if you look at the history of many of
these things so lucid dreaming
its history is in tibetan buddhism for
for a long time these buddhists and
these monks have been practicing it and
they call it dream yoga it's one of
their six main principles
why do they do it um they're it's a
vehicle for enlightenment but what does
that mean so
that's how they perceive it but what do
we look at enlightenment and all of
these things in the
islamic lens we see as something
different because to them what may be
enlightenment or
unity with the divine org or something
like that may just be
jin possession or maybe well jin's
giving them visions in something
or something along those lines so i
think we
we need to like put it in perspective um
and i think we need to look at these
benefits and see
is it worth it because there's a lot of
negatives that a lot a lot of people
don't talk about
um and a lot of things that can happen
when you're in these states that
are already messed up um especially
psychedelic states like people who take
lsd and dmt and psilocybin and mexican
and all of these drugs
you can have really amazing blissful
experiences no doubt but
some of them are crazy dark and you may
know of some and you may have heard of
some and
uh you you know um it's it's
it's a whole different world and the
quranic position is
sure these things have benefits and this
is harder in general not necessarily not
even magic but
drugs in general they have some benefit
to them but the harm
far outweighs the benefit you may see
the harmony may experience it or you may
not but if you don't see it in this
world you'll definitely see here in the
heart hereafter
and we'll look at maybe one verse later
in surah
ayah 102 which talks about the end how
the magicians sell their sell their
souls basically
um they're selling the hereafter so you
can't have both
no none everything and don't take that
loosely i do i don't want to jump on
oh go ahead finish your car i wanted to
i'm pretty much done
good so i do want to say that uh in a
hadith
the
sometimes they give true predictions and
he said that it pertains
to a hearing that they snatch from the
angels so the jinn
will try and overhear the angel speaking
obviously the angels are speaking truth
so they they learn something and they
take that back to the suit there
and they mix that truth with a hundred
lies so
that's why sometimes it seems like what
they're saying is true so the problem
has saying that
that that is how they do it not only
that that the person that goes to a
soothsayer and believes him has
disbelieved in the prophet muhammad
this is a very important point because
like brotherhood was saying it appears
that sometimes there are benefits right
but it's the same thing that prophet
muhammad was saying about the suits
there that
there's one little truth mixed with a
hundred lies so the person does dmt
and they have this experience like wow
you know i changed my life i used to be
an alcoholic now i
stopped i used to have all these
problems now i stopped so
there's one little one little thing that
he
held onto that he saw as a benefit but
it's mixed with a hundred other
falsehoods and false realizations
about him about his life and i remember
this one guy used to do brazilian jiu
jitsu at a gym
and one of the instructors was talking
about how uh
doing uh tripping on acid changed his
life he had a better relationship with
his wife
um he used to be a a worse person but
acid helped him realize that you know he
should take care of his son and he
should be there for him and
i'm like man you don't need acid to come
to that realization he was like yeah but
it's a shortcut i had so many problems
in my life but now i'm doing better
and fast forward years later i i mean
years later
right i see someone that used to go to
that gym and i'm like yo how is
someone so instructed and he's like nah
man he's not doing well man that guy was
tripping out
saying that he's god saying that he's so
he just had a mental breakdown you know
so that's and that is you know
that is really the experience if you go
on forum after
forum and problem after problem and
people going through the dmt and iowa
experience
this is like 90 of the time you see that
people are like yeah it's so good it's
so amazing i changed my life
dmt is amazing and there they become
trumpeters
right for dmt they wanna they become
callers to this almost like a religion
right
but later on fast forward mental
breakdowns
experiencing mental health issues uh
lack of concentration
they experience they start experiencing
weird things in their life
and that it and we'll get into why that
is later
but it's um
it's because what prophet muhammad
well he explained it one truth mixed
with a hundred lies so the person sees
that one truth
but they ignore that there's a hundred
lies surrounding you know and they're
and that that guy's experience where he
started having a mental breakdown saying
he was god and so forth
uh is quite common actually it's pretty
common
you know and and there's uh there's a
reason for that
because that path right is the same path
of all of the other
branches of magic and it all leads to
the same thing which is
someone replacing almighty god
with either himself or with shaitaan you
know
and then that's the system that they
believe in and they believe in it in
different ways so either
they'll just straight up say i'm a god
the way that pharaoh does
or they'll say they'll try and explain
it in some mystical way oh no
everything's god and we're all one with
god and by
removing your ego right i can remove the
illusion of myself
and i can be one with god and this is
also how many
cults started this is also how many
religions
that were false started um so for
example you had
a person saying look i remove myself i'm
one with god
right but what we have instead of that
is the abrahamic faith all of the
prophets peace be upon muhammad
sallallahu jesus peace be upon him
ibrahim peace be upon him what did all
of
um moses adam what did all of them say
they said
god is your creator and you are his
slave and you're here to serve god
right so we know that the message of the
prophets was never that
but then you have an another group right
this is almost like light and dark two
parallels are running throughout history
then you have another group saying no
you can be
god you can become one with god right
and this is nothing more than and they
and they they believe that when they do
this they can have certain powers they
can
feel certain energies and this is
nothing more than
again branches of magic or people
following the footsteps of shape on so
for dmt right
it's them communicating with the jinn
because historically shamans did this so
that they could communicate with the
jinn
for yoga it's the same thing you're
doing certain practices and certain
breathing movements so that
the jin can enter into you buddhism
basil projection and if you look at the
connection between ace for projection
experience that people have on ace
projection versus the experience that
people have
with dmt it's very very very similar so
for example some people on dmt
will say okay we take the emt and we can
have sex with the dmt entities
right and then same thing with acer
projection i do a sort of projection i'm
not saying i do is what i'm saying
someone said i do acer projection and i
can
meet the different entities and i can
even have sex with some of them if i
wanted to or if they were the
appropriate entity to have sex
so you see that right
and you see that each each branch of
magic is basically leading to the same
thing
but the way that we have it in modern
society that it's packaged as if it was
something else and sometimes even
packages if it's
uh religious so you have christian
groups
they'll say okay this is
this is the holy spirit entering in me
right and that's how they'll explain it
and then you have you have muslims some
groups
will say okay this is me being
one with allah and i'm just doing these
extra dikka and extra rituals
but when you look at the ritual it's
very similar to
and i'm talking about some extreme sufi
groups that do this you look at the
ritual it's very close to a shaman
ritual
right and instead of saying um
or like what a buddhist would do or
hindu would do they'd say
allah right so you you just gave a
little islamic twist to it to get
muslims to come in
to it but when you look at the practice
the practice is
not from islam it's something else and i
just i just wanted to add something
quickly that
brother gabriel was speaking on in one
episode that we did that
in islam all acts of worship or ibadah
they're all haram
unless stated that they're halal right
this is very
different than other things like when in
regards to
you know dunya things or intimacy these
things are more everything is halal
unless stated otherwise and we should
always be on guard
against vida which is a type of worship
that the prophet muhammad didn't mandate
and there was a hadith where three men
came up to
i
you know he he fasts sometimes and he
eats sometimes
and he prays at night sometimes and he
sleeps at night sometimes and sometimes
he
uh doesn't have uh relations with his
with his wives and sometimes he does
so then the three men each one was like
i'm gonna fast and i'm never going to
break my fast and the other one said i'm
going to pray all night and i'm never
going to sleep at night
and the third one said i'm never going
to have sexual relations with any woman
and they left and when the prophet
muslim heard that that
from his wife that they were saying that
he said i fast and i break my fast
sometimes
and i sleep with my wives and i
stand that night in prayer and i also go
to sleep and this is my sunnah and
whoever
and whoever tries to not do that is not
from the muslims
so these guys were doing that extreme
monk
they had that extreme monk mentality
that clearly if i do more i'll be i'll
do better
right and problem hold on no don't do
that that's that's a form of extremism
right and we we see that it's such a
it's such a blessing that
muslims have this because there's
there's a very
important hadith where an an important
muslim
uh passes away and
a solar eclipse happens at that time and
the muslims think oh
it must have been a solar eclipse
because of the death of
prophet i believe it was prophet
muhammed says no that's that's just
solar eclipse
it doesn't happen because of the death
of any one of you so you see that
prophet muhammad
teaching the muslims at the time to use
their mind
to use their reason what's what's allah
saying
do they not comprehend do they not think
do they not have
uh minds or or even do they not have
hearts that they comprehend with
so allah is telling you to think and
sometimes the
the father would say we follow the
religion of our fathers
and allah
or think about anything like this so
allah is
always telling people to think whereas
if we look at these dmt
things these yoga paths all of these
different pathways
that come from the same branches of
magic what is it
empty out your mind don't think about
anything surrender
all of your body and your mind to this
uh force or to this energy that you're
feeling
so you look at the difference the last
thing you think and use your brain
and this other path is saying no
surrender surrender your body give it
all up
it doesn't matter if you feel really bad
about it just just keep going
you know it'll get better it'll all make
sense and
oh that's exactly what these people do
they say oh yeah
yeah i don't want to cut you off but i
just want to say um there's
these two paths some refer to it as the
right hand path and the left hand path
and they refer to that in occultism so
this idea of the right-hand path is you
know like the
islamic faith christian faith the uh the
jewish faith of
we don't take magic we don't deal with
it it's wrong even though some
jews do maybe get into that but um like
it's being pure from that and connecting
with god and surrendering
submission is the is the idea and islam
is the most right-hand path because it
literally means submission and
we as me as muslims have not been
created except to worship allah
that's our purpose in life
um but the left hand path is the idea
that
you can become god and this is this is a
message
common with people who take psychedelics
like i connected with god i became one
with god i became
a god um and others
say similar things like um you know you
are god and they say more directly
so this forbidden practice and and these
practices of magic and
this these occult these are called
groups
they take this left-hand path quite
openly and they'll speak about it and
they'll say we reject the right-hand
path we take this left-hand path
um magic is good and there's we can grow
and have power and increase our money
and increase
this and our dominance on earth they go
on and on and on
so yeah it's a it's a dark dark thing
man i got i got a lot of things that i
want to say
so um insha allah i remember everything
here
but one of the things first off is the
fact
of what you're referring to the
extremism and the hadith
you see that a lot in citizen i believe
i'm saying it correctly correct me if
i'm wrong
yeah but it it's what the uh the yogis
do
where like they don't eat they they
don't have anything they're just like
traveling and they're just
all shriveled up like bones and they
believe
that they will reach enlightenment
like this yeah and that's
crazy and i mean if you even if you were
to look into it
the buddha himself said no this isn't it
like i did this i was about to die
and um i i literally i had to eat food
and all the aesthetics were basically
looking down on me
it's like all right well you can see
clearly in and of yourself okay well
the the thing that's like saying to do
that is also saying not to do that so
there's a lot of confusion
and um that's for people if they try to
ask questions and they want to know more
was like look at islam there is no
confusion
in in the real islam in the quran there
is no confusion
it's all very clear-cut so that's the
first thing i want to say
second thing i want to say is that this
is very true
when people start going down the path of
uh
the left path you were saying where they
they start to believe all this hype
you know and there's uh there's this
brother
here on youtube i think his name is uh
connor murphy
yeah he's he's on you yeah so he's uh
he's this big dude he was a
a fitness youtuber then he he started
losing his hair
um so he he got off all the gear that he
was on
because you guys know if you're on gear
steroids
and all those compounds it's going to
make you lose hair faster if you have
that genetic predisposition
so this man was starting to lose his
hair got off all the gear
started losing his gains started to get
his hair back
but then it's like in the process of
losing his gains
he was looking for something else so he
got into the new age
stuff yeah like all like the real
in-depth
yoga stuff and that's the next point
that i want to make you so if
i if i forget remind me it has to do
with yoga and meditation
but um he got into the new way stuff he
had a uh
a talk with muhammad hijab and
it was supposed to be i guess it was
supposed to be a debate but it ended up
just being a conversation
and then he later made a video saying
that he was muslim
and i was like subhanallah but in the
same video that he said he was muslim
he also said that he is god damn
and i was like oh yes come on now
i saw a video now i was so confused i
was i watched
that conversation between muhammad and
connor and i was like well this is
actually a mad conversation i checked
out his channel
then i saw that video and i was like yo
this is mad and then i saw
him say that i was like okay cool like
if he's just starting off obviously
you're going to make mistakes you're not
going to know
necessarily right from wrong so he just
needs a bit of like
like a helping hand we need to be like a
gen like generous and kind and
show them like look man this is the way
uh yes i don't know what it's up to now
i've seen a couple of like good stuff
but insha'allah guys
i literally saw that and he was like i'm
god your god anyone can be god and i was
like okay
cool muhammad made that video he even
posted and said muhammad hijab converted
me to islam
a month later he posted another video
saying oxford professor converts me back
to atheism
and there was some some guy there was
some uh i forgot his name but he's a
he's a really skinny scrawny looking
dude he's a very
outspoken atheist youtuber and it's not
you know any ex-muslim
and he basically made a video converting
him back to atheism which i don't even
know how you can convert atheism
but he basically left islam in that
video you know what i think he has to do
but he probably was never a muslim in
the first place
god he never really understood the
message he just yeah
i i remember these kind of people
honestly what happens is
whatever feels good in the moment that's
what they're going to follow
so i remember one time there was this
guy was like yeah you know i'm muslim i
had this amazing experience blah blah
blah
i asked him a question i was like why
are you muslim
is it because of this amazing experience
so if you were to have a random
experience
where uh it would it involved something
from a different religion would you just
leave your faith and go to a different
faith and what if you had a third
experience and a fourth experience and a
fifth experience what are you going to
do then
so i said you have to have a reason here
too you have to have the mind as well
it's good that you're having
this experience but that's not the
be-all and end-all we also have to use
our minds too to come to the appropriate
conclusion
damn that raises another point yo i feel
like this
this is going to be good episodes
inshallah inshallah
but um i hope the introduction was good
i feel like we were all over the place
that's because it's a hard topic to talk
about
and there's so many things to cover and
you feel like you're
becoming a crazy person trying to tell
people you know the conspiracy theorist
that has all these
thoughts connected pictures it's all
connected guys you know so it's kind of
like
you're trying to explain that but it's
very hard to begin
even so that's why i like if you guys
ask us questions that's
a lot easier than us trying to just
overload everyone with information
and explain all the concepts but yeah it
makes sense
it makes sense but um to finish off what
i'm going to say here so we can
wrap the ep up and then head into the
next one inshallah
with with what you said right with uh
this brother conor murphy
um number one it is he's just kind of
like going with what he feels
anyone who's in the new age stuff they
just go with what they feel
and i like to i'd like to refer it
exactly to um this ep that we have with
um
i think his name is mahdi
how do you say it
he he had said in one of the parts when
i had left the
video because i had to do something that
um
before someone in islam
begins to look into other religions to
understand their perspective where
they're coming from or even atheism to
understand where they're coming from
they need to be firm
in their belief in their deen because if
not then they will be easily
swayed and fire was even going into uh
some slight examples here and there how
like uh
what were you saying about the atheism
like when you were looking into it was
kind of like
shaking you when i when i started
practicing islam
because even as born muslims a lot of
these brothers and sisters can relate to
me when i say that
everyone has a turning point when they
kind of get ten toes down into the deen
you know some people have already always
stated i stayed on dean but i'm
for the other people so when they come
back to dean they start you know
learning about the
being and you know getting more into
their conviction and they find all these
channels like david wood
you know and all these you know atheist
arguments and we're not gonna lie
the new person into islam who's not too
knowledgeable these arguments do seem
true because he's quoting
quran and hadith and all that and i'm
saying to the average layman
if they don't have a firm conviction in
islam all
it might take is a little bit of you
know the other side's arguments
for them to start questioning their
faith whereas i was advising people that
it's much better
if you're new into islam to fully
understand islam
then and prioritize that then after
you've done that learn about the
religions
i do say the second part is important as
well because it's it's not until you
fully understand the other person's or
the other party's arguments
that you can fully understand why they
think the way they think and why we
think the way we think and how to fully
you know affirm your conviction and see
the holes in their narrative or in their
logic
i think that's very important too
because it it goes with these saying
like you have to stand for something or
you fall for anything
yeah there was this there was a saying
that i was referring to called the
know thy enemy like you know just
basic warfare and stuff like that like
you need to know the opposing side
and how they operate to kind of
you know just make everything more
seamless yeah but you need to know
yourself first
you got to know yourself first bro and
it's more important to know yourself
than to know the enemy but it's more
important to know the enemy once you
know yourself than to just
only know yourself only know everything
through the lens that you see
in your biases
that they forgot allah so allah made
them forget themselves
and they didn't they didn't remember
allah
they didn't bring their prayers to allah
they didn't they didn't think about
allah made them
forget themselves and then you see it
these people get forget themselves they
get lost
they start talking mumbo jumbo they
don't know what they're talking about
someone's saying i'm god that's clearly
someone who's lost in the sauce you know
because all it takes is the basic
question we know you're going to die
what do you mean your god
right but no these people don't they
don't want to see
logic and reason they call muslims
fanatics but they themselves are the
biggest fanatics
and then they make fun of people of
other religions and they say oh you guys
follow dogma
we don't we don't follow dogma we're
free and enlightened
but they are the biggest followers of
dogma right
and believing things without any
evidence
anything that they feel that they saw in
their in their psychedelic
trips or experiences that becomes the
ultimate reality for them
they don't question just like how you'd
question a human on the street
and ahimashi says oh i'm i'm the ceo of
microsoft i'm like oh really what's your
name
oh well my name is michael i thought
bill gates was the ceo
of microsoft like no no it's a michael
i'm
that it would be silly if someone just
believed that but people that have these
psychedelic experiences
that they trip and they they have these
breakthrough experiences they just
believe whatever the entities tell them
they don't they don't think the question
okay what if this entity is lying
what if uh what if this is actually not
true they just whatever they see
or whatever they hear they think okay
that must be the truth
and it's the same thing with people that
follow gurus whatever the guru said it
must be true
i'm not gonna question it but allah says
repeatedly in the quran
question ask questions people used to
come to the prophet muhammad something
that didn't make sense they asked a
question
you look at prophet ibrahim when talking
to the idol worshipers
he would ask them do these idols speak
do these idols talk can they benefit me
right so allah is consistently saying
look do you have this mind it's a gift
you use it and you have the prophets
coming and they're not just saying oh
just believe without any evidence
not only did they they tell you to think
and use their brain they also used
they also showed the people miracles to
give them further evidence and saying
look you know here's a miracle but
honestly from what i've if you if you
look into it
a lot of the times you don't really need
a miracle
you just you you just need to use your
brain and think a little bit
allah says for those people asking for a
sign
haven't hasn't allah already shown
enough signs look at the moon look at
the sky look at the stars look at the
trees
look at yourself your way your your body
is right and
the dna and everything that you have in
you is that isn't that all enough of the
sun
so then allah asks a question
were they created from nothing or did
they create themselves so when someone
says oh i'm a god
did you create yourself what do you mean
you're a god he's like no no but i don't
mean it in that way i mean
all of us are god and our our um
our individuality is an illusion and so
forth okay
if your individuality is an illusion uh
sell your home
give me your children uh give me your
wife let me have all because it's
basically giving it if you're giving it
to me it's like you're giving it to
yourself so just give me everything you
have give me all your money too
but again some people do do stuff like
that they'll give everything they have
to their guru or to their cult leader
[Music]
right and they lose themselves and they
lose their lives and their minds not
only to the psychedelic experience
but also to the guru and you hear so
many stories of people that follow guru
there's one
uh i think it was in the 90s say baba
who he said he was a god and he had many
many followers
and then allegations came out about him
having sexual relations with the little
boys and his
and his um i don't know what you call a
congregation
uh many people came out and said you
know he's a sexual predator
and you know at infinite man it's all it
happens all the time
people give up their minds that's it
whether they give up their mind to the
guru or that they give up their mind for
the psychedelic experience
the end result is the same you know when
just to wrap up like when we say
people sell their souls even though
we're saying they sell their souls i
mean we could mean them literally it
also does mean that they're selling
their bodies
and also their their mind so they're
either going to become sick
and be inflicted with disease or some
kind of physical sickness
and it's usually sicknesses that the
doctors are like we don't know what this
is we can't cure it
or they'll be inflicted with mental
disorders and they'll just end up going
crazy for a lack of a better word
they'll just absolutely lose it
so they'll sell their souls yeah but
they also have negative effects and
books have been written about written
about this from the islamic paradigm so
i think there was this one that i was
reading recently called gin and human
sickness
and a lot of sickness and a lot of
madness can be caused
not always sometimes it is natural right
you do have natural schizophrenia and so
on but a lot of it can be caused with
magic and interaction with gin so
it's a it's you're never going to get
any any real good from it and if you do
get good from it it's not going to be
worth it because you're selling either
your body
or your mind or both or your soul so
yeah
just know what you're doing yeah and
it's
it's um it's a very ungrounded type of
practice
it all leads to ungroundedness like
there's no stability
versus if you're in islam there is
stability there is groundedness
and um i think the last thing that i
want to throw in here
is and we can talk about this in the
next video for sure
right because this is something that i'm
sure a lot of people
are curious and they want to know about
and that's the whole thing about
the different forms of meditation
and yoga because it's like look they are
like if you come to the west the yoga
that you see in the west
guys that's just stretching it's
literally like
very light form of exercise with
stretching there is
nothing crazy about it and then the
meditation practices that
you primarily see over here is basically
um just like a self-reflection
based exercise or a focus
based exercise where you're just trying
to focus on
maybe a sound or what your your
breathing pattern or something like that
but it's like there are different forms
and like the true yoga and the true
meditation
are the ones that really lead you down
that path i mean i've had experience
with it but
inshallah we can all get into this in
the next episode
all right guys type down
smokeless fire so we know who made it
this far
and i'll let brother ahmed wrap it up
with a few thoughts and
maybe a quick teaser no more than a
minute of what they can expect the next
episode
yes and it i would say that this is part
of a plot that when you give
yoga as just stretching and then you
give meditation
as just self-reflection but you call it
those things so that people say oh i had
a positive experience
then they go down that road not
realizing what's at the end of those
experiences
very similar to psychedelic experience
or even when people smoke weed
they have a good positive experience but
then
later on down the road when that when
they're at the point of no return
and they've had too much damage done to
them that's when they're like oh wait
there was something sinister going on
this whole time
i've been being tricked i've been being
lied to so inshallah in the next episode
we can talk about
uh the ufo experience and the history of
ufos america started project blue book
to look at uh whether ufos exist or not
in around 1947. so i'll give you guys
the results
of project blue book and it's public
information now i'll give you the
results of project blue look in the next
episode inshaallah
insha allah so with that
being said we'll wrap it up
with what ahmed said guys
you can do this thing you know you can
say that yourself
like you can say that you're stretching
you can say that you're exercising
and just leave it at that there's no
need to
say that you're meditating you're doing
yoga and
it's not to say that you can't but it's
just to say that
the way our mind works we always
search for more we we're never content
with what we have we're always looking
for more
so if you say oh i do yoga i do
meditation
well you're going to be open to
what's to come down that road because
we're always looking for more
but um with that being said that has
been the episode
um in sha a lot it helps you guys they
provide some
clarity maybe it even brings up some
questions that you guys can
start to look into yourselves um but
with that being said we will see you in
the next
ep
bless you all comment down below really
helps the algorithm and if you want to
know more on a fundamental basis
of gin um to the best of our abilities
check out episode 10
i will try to plug it in right now um in
episode 10 we go a little bit into like
the
just a bit basic gist of gin what they
are
some you know ayat from the quran so on
and so forth
surround yourself with good people not
bad people if you're in a position where
those around you are influencing you
negatively
more than you're influencing them
positively i think you need new friends
[Music]
me
[Music]
um